Telekom hinter das ist abgekackt ganz toll ganz grandios Telekom Lull
Aber ein offer watch account hat sich ausgelockt auch gut blizzard account noch mal aus
So ich hoffe ich hoffe streben geht wieder
Telekom Lull
Sollte sollte eigentlich wieder alles funktionieren schreibt mal bitte in chat ob es wieder geht
Ich gucke gerade mal muss kann man bei mir selbst gucken ja ne ja sieht so aus als geht's wieder
sehr schön
Telekom Lull
Tja
Kann man leider nichts machen wenn die Telekom sagt du spielst jetzt kein offer watch dann
So f5 go go go
Ihr solltet eigentlich kein plex screen mehr haben ihr solltet jetzt offer watch sehen wieder
Ah fuck ich wollte instinktiv irgendwie da drauf klicken gerade
So weiter geht's
Angeblich habe ich auch null viewer und alles im arsch
Alters 2cp soll ich mich verarschen
Weil so viel 2cp warum
Mal gucken was die jungs hier picken
Glaubst du es lohnt sich eine switch zu kaufen oder sollte ich ihr bis anfang 2018 warten warum willst du warten wenn es dafür jetzt games gibt
Ich weiß dass es nicht nur cp ist so jetzt ist es 1cp
Ja auf pickt was leute
Pickt irgendwas ich habe ja gar keine skins hier
Keine skins rib da geht nichts rein ohne skins da kann einfach nichts reingehen
Ich muss mir jetzt mal den neuen hält angucken was hatten die für fähigkeiten
Heal? Heal? Damage? Shift ist so ein evade und e
Hey das ist ja mal ein komplexer support char was ist mit blizzard los was geht denn da komplexer support char ich glaub es nicht
Das kann doch nicht sein komplexer support char
Rett nicht weg kann man sich selbst heilen wie heilt man sich selbst mit dem heilball
Ich wusste ich muss den heil erstmal ausprobieren
erste mal dass ich den spiele jetzt hab null
kann man kann man ich vermute mal man kann sich so selbst heilen wenn man sich wenn man die heilkugel gegen sich schießt
hoffe ich mal
Ach rechtsklick ist live steel
Meine jungs machen das easy life get carried ich muss nix machen
Wisst ihr wie sich das anhört
Wisst ihr wie sich das anhört es hört sich an wie ein wasserkocher
fast mal auf
Wieder hier reingerannt ist
Wat was ist das alter da kann sie überhaupt nicht hielen
Da kann sie überhaupt nicht hielen
Okay, das ist kein symmetra style
Kein symmetra style ding das ist irgendwie
Ne das war damit ich muss hier machen
Jetzt reicht es mal baschen alter
Wobei wir gucken uns die ult noch mal an
Du brauchst nicht da du brauchst nicht zielen ist das wie
das ist wie
doch so so symmetra style
Okay, ich muss erst mal eh ist das ist heilkugel, okay auf gang go komm her
Was hat das für ne range alter was hat das für ne range
Alter was hat das für ne range das ist doch nicht normal
Ich weiß nicht was ich hier so genau mache ehrlich gesagt
Schreckt
So spielt man zwar eigentlich kein supporter ich hab mich zu aber warum ist das so
Okay naja weil man sich daran gewöhnt geht das doch warum haben wir den punkt eigentlich gerade eingenommen
Ist so halb symmetra du musst mehr zielen, okay
Fliegt doch nicht weg
Okay, da muss ich erst mal dran gewöhnen aber das geht schon
Aber
Warum hast du den neuen account gemacht weil ich kein bock hab
Mit meinem main account quasi indirekt die games zu throne bis ich auf einem angemessen skill level bin
Aber mein account ist ja immer noch obwohl ich aufgehört habe zu spielen ende sie sind vier selber noch heimaster law grandmaster
Eingerangt so intern im intern flizzard matchmaking
rating also nicht das was angezeigt wird sondern das was quasi an
In
An den account gebunden ist und da müsste ich jetzt erst mal wahrscheinlich 30 matches verlieren weil ich halt sacken und das game nicht mal kann
Bis ich dann wieder runter bin so auf lau master diamond oder sonst was
Easy wird es werden geschreckt
Wenn das game wiederACTION keinen unreal beустить werden muss man erst wieder
Achtung auch an den runter geworfen
Habe ich auch immer mehr gerade was fliegen sehen?
HAHA!
Welche Season ist das gerade? Das müsste die Season 6 oder so sein.
Schöner Fahrer?
Schneiber!
Boah! Fuck!
Hast du den Reinhardt-Film geschaut? Ja! Fand ich geil!
Reinhardt-Film war echt super gemacht! Will der Reaper sich dann mal heilen oder so?
So an den Berg!
Erst mal wieder reinkommen in das Game!
John D.Va?
Bastion? Was soll der da machen?
Smurfst du? Naja, ich würde es nicht Smurf nennen! Ich mache mir den Account meinem Skill-Level angemessen!
Ich zacke halt in dem Game aktuell noch! Muss ich erst mal wieder reinfinden!
Was? Das hat nicht getroffen!
Reckt!
Wo kommt die Fahrer her?
1,2,3 BÄM!
Der kommt da jetzt lang!
Was machen die?
Was ist das?
Easy clap!
Warum bist du damals aus deinem Team raus? Ich bin nicht aus meinem Team raus!
Das ist eine längere Geschichte!
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr so genau ehrlich gesagt!
Ich bin nicht aus meinem Team raus! Das hat irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz funktioniert!
Das hat sich auch mehr oder weniger aufgelöst!
Das hat doch doof gewesen! Ja, das ist eigentlich total doof gewesen!
Das hat übernübelst Bock gemacht!
Mein legendärer! Mein Hanzo zeigt euch nicht!
Ihr zeigt dein Hanzo, wie sich das anhört!
Hanzo!
Ich zeige euch gleich mein legendärer Winston!
Dass der mich richtig gut aufgemacht hat!
Wo ist er hin?
Ich dachte, er hat sich wenigstens geheilt!
Ich höre einen Roadhog!
Was haben die denn überhaupt? Eine Fahrer? Okay, da muss ich aufpassen, dass mich keiner runter wirft!
Da ist schon einer!
Reaper? Wo ist er?
Ich höre links was neben mir! Ich muss mal runter!
Ein Soldier am Start! Alter, verpiss dich!
Ich höre hinter mir was! Ich muss weg!
Ich höre ihn von links, kam Roadhog!
Oh!
Ich höre ihn von rechts!
Komm her!
Exord. Exord. Belgier Heroes sind aktuell Meta. Winston. Winston, D.Va, Genji, Jax,
Tracer. Wo ist der, sag mal. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Willst du mich nicht rocken?
Da. Haben wir das jetzt? Können wir das jetzt mal kriegen, ja? Ist das möglich?
Oh, oh. Äh, wenn, ich sage, ich sage, das ist, das ist ein Level 2 Game. Die sind halt,
die haben das, im Vergleich zu mir, die haben das halt alle nicht gespielt. Aber ich bin
schlecht, glaubt's mir. Ich kann das einschätzen mittlerweile. Halt gegen die Leute nicht,
aber gegen, gegen Ultra Noobs sieht man immer gut aus. Habe ich doch gehört von der Seite.
I've got you in my sights. Easy clapped. Ähm. Oh, oh, oh. Na, was gucken? Habe ich, habe
ich, habe ich Q gedrückt? Wie das, das geht Play of the Game. Was hab ich da gemacht?
Ich hab wohl vor der Fahrer geholtert, als ich das drauf zu schieben. Oh, und das natürlich.
Play of the Game. Easy Play of the Game. Easy. Die Fahrer steht auf Boots on the Ground.
Die sollte besser World War 2 spielen. Äh, was hatte ich eigentlich, Accuracy, ähm, hallo?
Ich will nicht mein Secondary Fire sehen, aber 67, 67, ähm, 67% Helix Rockets treffen
ist nicht übel. So, Defend, komm. Der Torb, der Torb geht ab. Okay, ich warte erst mal,
was die anderen picken. Symmetra, Mercy. Ah, der, der Torb ist real. Wobei ich brauche
den. Der Torb hat auch ungefähr Self. Hat auch so was wie Self viel. Warum neuer Account?
Weil mein Main Account seit Season 4 im internen Blizzard Matchmaking Rating nicht wirklich
gefallen ist. Und ich sacke in dem Game einfach mittlerweile. Also sacken ist vielleicht das
falsche Wort, aber ich bin nicht mal wirklich drinne in dem Game. Ich hab kein Bock, quasi
indirekt Games zu, zu throwen für Leute, die halt wirklich auf diesem Rating sind. Bis
Blizzard dann, das Blizzard Matchmaking erkannt hat, dass ich eben auf einen niedrigeren Rating
gehören. Deswegen mach ich mir neuer Account. Außerdem hat es, Overwatch hat halt keine
Möglichkeiten zum Üben. Es gibt in Overwatch halt, okay doch jetzt vielleicht mit Team
Wars Match gibt es die Möglichkeit zu üben, ja. Aber es gibt in Overwatch keine, Quickplay
ist halt shit fest. Das ist ja noch ne halb, ne das ist für Quickplay noch ne gute Kopf,
was wir hier haben, ja. Ja. Es gibt eigentlich keine Möglichkeit zu üben, außer halt Private
Lobbies zu machen mit Leuten, die es ernst nehmen. Deswegen ist ganz gut, kann ich mich
fix einspielen. Oh, ich hab vorbei geschossen.
Wow, der kann ja moveen. Was soll das? An was bin ich denn eben erst noch gestorben?
Ich bin gestorben, hallo. Noch nicht mal der Torb kann es retten hier. Ich mal der Torb
hier. Ey, mein Turret. Go, go, Torb, move dich, beweg dich. Nicht alle sterben Leute,
vor, vor, vor, vor. Gleich gibt es Molten Core. Gleich ist Molten Core angesagt. So.
Warum trefft niemand vor mich? Die treffen ja alle nichts. Ich bin hier der typische
Quickplay Torb gerade. Der typische Quickplay Torb. Was? Was? Nein. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah.
Ey, ich hab's mal gleich gemacht. Oh, wir haben Teleporter. Was? Was? Was zum Teufel?
Was ist das für ein Teleporter? Oh, oh, Achtung, Achtung, links, links, links, links.
Ich bin schon eine Fahrer. Was ist hier los?
Komm, komm, lade. Torb. Alter. Ah.
Hier, Reaper, nimm.
Die Rüstung ist Keksexplosiv, richtig. Ich find das geil, wie überfordert man von
einem Game sein kann, wenn man das eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt hat. Aber wie er mich
da rausgeultet hat, fand ich das war nice. Nee, nee, das Turret hat nicht Max Level
2. Das Turret hat Max Level 3. Allerdings braucht man natürlich ein Level 2 Turret
und muss seine Ulti toppen. Komm, die machen jetzt noch einen Push. Easy.
Ja. Ich muss mich jetzt nicht so feiern, wenn
ich die Rüstung nicht mehr gespielt habe, also ich level 2 am Besche. Zieh rein, ja.
So. Macht sie so Geräusche. Ah, das ist dieses, dieses S-Team.
Ähm, Sam Fischer, kannst du machen, ja? Jaja, lass uns, lass uns ne Runde zusammenspielen.
Gib mir XP. Immer schön für sich selbst. Klar, was, was denn sonst? Was denn sonst?
Plays. Huge Plays. Lootbox, ganz wichtig. Um so das bisschen, ähm, Battlefront-Feeling
aufkommen zu lassen. Passend der Top-Spray. Der Top-Spray, den brauch ich. Ja, Sam Fischer,
dann, äh, gib mir mal deinen, deinen, ähm, Battle-Dings da. Account. Oh, ein Reihardskin,
jawoll. Ja, schick mir mal deinen Battle-Tag. BenatwitchTV spackt übelst rum auf der neuen
Seite. Ich kann, ich kann, ich kann den Chat auf der Seite gar nicht mehr aufmachen. So.
Search noch. Ja, DevilQ bis, bis 25 dauert schon ein bisschen. Ähm, ich bin jetzt auf
meinem Hauptrechten übrigens umgestiegen von BenatwitchTV auf, äh, Frankyourfacesz plus
BenatwitchTV Emoji Addon. Funktioniert mehr als mit BenatwitchTV zur Zeit und vor allem
hat es ein ordentliches Dark-Scene wieder. Also, war eine Frage an euch. Twitch hat jetzt
ja offiziell so einen Dark-Modus. Ich finde den. Also ich fand den alten von BenatwitchTV
besser. Weil das, das ist jetzt so, so lila, lila dunkel irgendwie. Und das gefällt mir
nicht. Dieses grau dunkel hat mir viel besser gefallen. Jop, Sam Fischer, ich edde dich
nach der Runde. Die Runde spielen wir noch. Ja, das Purple Dark-Steam ist crap. Ja, finde
ich auch. Sag mal, was haben wir denn jetzt? Hanzo? Hanzo Repair. Der Klassiker. Der Klassiker.
Ich, ich, ich spiele alle Supports. Na gut, Meura hab ich schon nicht gespielt. Außer
ich spiele keine Mercy. Aus Prinzip nicht. Hasse, ich hasse Mercy. Ich, ich weiß gar
nicht, warum da so viele drauf abgehen. Mercy ist so der, so der, der One Trick hält in
Overwatch schlechthin. Ui. Zum Meta. Ich heil dich, ich heil dich Kollege. Das war
nur schon mal ein Speed. Ich krieg mich da mal ein. Oh Mann. Das war nur schon mal ein
Spiel. Das hat von der Brücke gefallen. Okay, auf jetzt hier. Concentration. Oh mein Scheiß,
das ist quick. Lasst euch heilen Leute, haut nicht ab. Jetzt ist die Symmetra. Verpisst
dich. Hau auf Hanzo. Was ist hier los? Lasst euch heilen, warum rennt ihr alle weg? Warum
rennt ihr alle weg vor Heal? Was ist das? Warum rennt ihr nicht alle weg? Achtung jetzt
wieder. Ui. Ich hab, ich hab einen Teleporter gehört.
Oh nee, gescattered, gescattered. Eieiei. Oh, ich bin ein Solo Healer. Solo Healer als
jetzt nicht so tolle. Moment kurz, ich seh Chat nicht. Bester Spot. Auf Leute, rein da,
rein da. Hanzo. Hanzo. Was macht die hier? Oh, oh, weg hier. Was, der hat mich getroffen.
Fuck's net. Nope. Ich weiß, dass du zum Heal wolltest. Alter, so nicht. Lebt er noch?
Nein, nein. Was ist hier drinne los? Ich glaub, mit so Port funktioniert das doch nicht so
gut. Nein, was machst du? Alter. Ui. So, ich bleib jetzt hier stehen. Ich bleib jetzt
hier stehen bis Regroup wird. Fertig. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Direkt, direkt. Nice, easy, easy
Tire. Komm jetzt Leute, komm, go, go. Achtung, die. Auf, komm, komm jetzt Leute, komm. Was
ist denn hier los drinne? Vor allem, es kommt auch keiner mit, ne? Ich hab halt keinen Bock.
Das sind die Turrets. Ok, ich spiel das für irgendwas anderes. Normalerweise kannst du
King of the Hill oder Lucio gar nicht richtig spielen, aber ey, ich mein, das sind ja für
das, ja? Könnten wir mal spielen. Also man eigentlich, oh ne. Moira. Anna. Komm, ich
spiel mal Anna. Anna ist schon lange in der Mannschaft. Was hab ich denn für ne? Ah,
ich treff noch ein bisschen Wasser. Du musst ja das Level 3 Meter anpassen, ja? Den Clip
muss ich mir nachher angucken. Der Junkrat war zu geil, wie er da runtergeflogen ist. Erstmal
drinnen. Oh, boah. Die Granate fliegt so schonmal nicht mehr. Mach den platt, Alter. Gengu,
bleib stehen. Oh, fuck vollen. Welche Maus ich genommen hab? Ich hab eine Zoe EC2A. I
require healing. Healing braucht der Genji. Wer hätte das gedacht, dass er healing braucht?
Kennt man von Genjis gar nicht, dass sie healing brauchen. Ja, Leute. Ich seh nichts.
Das ist absolut random, ey. Das ist absolut random, ey. Du blickst da gar nicht durch.
Das ist vollkommen random. Ich glaub eigentlich kannst du nur Soldier spielen. Das ist so
absolut unkontrolliert, ey. So, Kenji, auf gehts. Oh, fuck. Nein, das wollte ich nicht.
Das ist echt, ne, das ist mir zu random. Du kannst kein Support spielen. Das funktioniert
nicht. Das ist einfach nur total verteilt und, ne. Aber wir können nicht ohne Support spielen.
Das klappt nicht. Auf, Soldier, mach ihn nochmal platt. Ah, ich hab keinen Bock drauf.
Oh, ist das blöd. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ey. Das funktioniert doch nicht. Support ist
für Pussys, ja. Das ist so total random, ey. Links zwei, rechts zwei, unten einer um,
einer um. Genji, please switch. Ja, das liegt nur am Genji. Eindeutig. Nur, nur. Was sonst?
Nur am Genji, sonst nichts. So, jetzt add ich mal hier den Sam Fischer. Wo ist er denn?
Ich hab dir eine Einladung geschickt. Ne, ne, Support kannst du eigentlich voll vergessen,
ey. Das braucht so ein... Ich mein, what? Ist das Boy oder Grill im Chat? Ich bin erst
mal auf dem Top 3. Das dauert ja ewig. Das dauert ja ewig. Leon... Ich bleib erst mal
hier DuoQ, sonst wird's... Sonst kriegt es das wahrscheinlich gar nicht gebacken. Weiß
man schon, wann die neuen Intel Boards rauskommen. Was für neue Intel Boards. Du meinst die
Z370 für Mittelklasse? Okay, was nehmen wir dann? Was nehmen wir dann? Alter. Saria. Vielleicht
kriegen wir ein bisschen Speed. Saria hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gespielt. Season
2 hab ich die glaub ich gespielt. Am meisten. Von allen Helden. Ich glaub Season 2 war das
Saria richtig gut war. Zuerst hab ich schon mal gelieft oder auch nicht? Wo krieg ich
denn eigentlich Erfolge für Spawn? Sieh ich das richtig? Ich hab grad Erfolg gekriegt,
dafür, dass ich gespawnt bin. Ah nee, das war der Erfolg für wir sind im Team im Game
getreut. Ich hab irgendwas im Hals, ist ja schlimm. Oh, wir sind in dem richtigen Game
gelandet. Jetzt sind hier gar nicht mehr so Vollbobs drinne. Ach nee, das liegt daran,
weil ich mit seinem Fischer gequeet bin. Das wird zu anstrengend. Was ist hier los?
Wo sind die alle hin? Sind die alle weg? Total.
Es ist total random, ich weiß noch einmal Spawn sein. Simple Geometry. Oh oh.
Ganz toll. Oh, wir haben Speed. Wir haben eigentlich so gut wie gewonnen schon.
Ach nee, schon so gut wie gewonnen. Das Gefieder ist der Wahnsinn. Was ist da los?
Huck mich. Will, dass du mich huckst. Haha.
Okay, mehr Konchette. Oh, sind alle drin. Sind alle drin. Sind alle drin. Ah, wir haben
eine Pulsbomb gekriegt, gut. Echte Gegner PogChamp, ja. Das sind wirklich echte Gegner.
Werft paar, werft. Wo ist er? Warum hat er, warum hat er Reaktionen der Chunkrat? Wo
sind meine Leute? Warum hat der Chunkrat so gute Reaktionen? Hat es nicht gezündet,
als der Lucius das Schild hatte? Was, was ist hier los? Den Hanzo juckt der Punkt absolut
nicht, dem ist das vollkommen egal. Der heißt bestimmt Legolahas oder so, wie heißt der
nicht. Das sind immer die besten, die so geile Namen haben. Hanzo-Main und Legolahas
und Legolahas. Den holen wir uns. Oder auch nicht. Achtung, die kommen, kommen die denn
ganz lang. Easy Clap. Oh nee Leute, Leute. Was, was, was? Wie hat er mich gekillt? Ach,
das war die, ach nee ich kack nur, das war die D.Va Bombe. Max spielt wieder Overwatch,
ja. Wir verlieren das auch noch. Und wisst ihr warum wir verlieren? Weil ich es verkackt
hab, weil ich oben rechts hingegangen bin, anstatt einfach mal meine Leute in der Mitte
zu babbeln. Richtig stumm, richtig stumm gewesen. Oh, oh, huge, huge, da geht er ab,
da geht er ab. Was, was, nein, nein. Der Chosen ist da, das ist schön. Ey, warum läutet
ich hier? Als Overwatch kehren da noch. Oh, war das schlecht, ey. Oh, war das schlecht.
Und ich muss mich hauen, ich muss mich dran gewöhnen, vor allem im aktuellen Meta, ich
muss was hicken. Das Wichtigste muss ich was hicken. Ich mach das immer noch nicht mit
genug Fokus. Außerdem mach ich viel zu wenig Damage für Zarya, ich meine keine Medaille,
das ist eigentlich für eine Zarya nicht. Malerweise muss der Alz Zarya, oh mein Power
up. Ich check's hier nicht, wo sind denn hier die Gegner überhaupt? Ach, da ist einer
auf den Punkt. Sagt es halt einer. Eine so. Merci. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Na, oh man, das ist doch schlecht wieder gewesen.
Es gibt
Ist das schlecht, Alter? Ich muss...
Mercy, äh, nicht Mercy, sondern
Saria kommt eigentlich hauptsächlich drauf an
also neben dem, dass man halt nicht
ihn ergrifft, dass man richtig steht
und so nicht
Du hast doch einen Smurf draußen
Oh, ihr braucht Schild
Hopp, jetzt haben Fischer Schilds gebraucht
Gengu, komm her
Juuuussch
Ah, ich habs probiert
Ich habe es probiert
Ne, Chosen, wenn du mitmachst
dann wär ich viel zu hoch eingerankt danach
wieder, weil du mich carriest
Keine Damage-Medal hier mit Saria
Das ist absolut lächerlich schlecht, ey
Hallo
Hallo, würde ich gerne schilden
Wo seid ihr denn, Leute?
Wo sind alle?
So schlecht!
Alter, ich hab mich selbst gekillt!
Was war das denn?
Oh, wie kacke!
Der Genji hat mich überfordert!
Das war zu viel gerade!
Auf Leute!
Kommt Leute!
Leute, macht das doch!
Ihr müsst den own!
Genji own!
Please!
Huge Crap!
Huge!
Aber erst mal selbst die Luft gesprengt!
Hallo Erx!
Hab ich überhaupt Easy Clap aktiviert?
Als Emote?
Wenn nicht, ist das ein fast nicht zu entschuldigendes Versäumnis!
Was könnte man hier eigentlich verspielen?
Und wir haben keinen Support?
Kann man auch nicht spielen!
Der bleibt Masaria!
Weil Orisa ist hier richtig gut!
Orisa online!
Mach doch mal den Genji platt, ey!
Meine Güte!
Ich pack's endlich!
Ich hab's!
Ich pack es nicht!
Die sind kack Genji, das gibt's doch nicht!
Oh, was mach ich denn hier?
Oh, sorry!
Ich hab's.
Nein!
Nein.
Überwatch ist ein Overwatch, ist Nixi-Rip, Leute!
Ich weiß, ich hab nur ganz kurz im Chat gesehen, dass es einer geschrieben hat!
haben ziemlich viele Zuschauer angezogen
Oh, ich hab, ich hab mich hochgearbeitet auf Silber
Oh, wir haben es, wir haben es, Leute, nicht den Punkt vergessen, nicht den Punkt vergessen
Oh, ne, ich hab nur noch Pause
Ja, und ihr wolltet mir nicht glauben, dass ich sacke, eh
Ist doch offensichtlich
Was, warum ist das Ding nicht gestorben grade?
Jetzt aber
Ja, das ist tatsächlich das Problem an Overwatch, dass das Rank-System sackt
Aber Overwatch an sich ist eines der geilsten Games der letzten Zeit, keine Frage
Good Box
Kannst du den Chat nach oben links verschieben?
Ja, kann ich machen
Aber dann sieht man die FPS nicht mehr
Weil was ist euch lieber? Chat oben rechts, Chat oben links, Chat unten links
Wir können Chat unten links machen
Was, oder unten rechts oder so
Hier ist das
Wo wollt ihr Chat?
Ich finde da oben rechts stört es eigentlich am wenigsten
Aber sucht es euch aus
Oben links, beste
Gut, oben links kann ich auch machen, das ist kein Ding
Ui, mach mal hier so, dass man noch FPS sieht, okay?
Ist das, ist das, ist das so gut?
Oben in der Mitte, ist das klar, stört es aber überhaupt nicht
Das Problem an Overwatch ist tatsächlich, glaube ich dir recht, dass das Rank-System sackt
Das ist so
Das Problem ist auch
Ranked soll ja so, das sagt der Blizzard zumindest, Ranked soll die Nachwuchsförderung für Overwatch League sein
Das Problem ist, dass ordentliche Teams komplett anders spielen, als es im Ranked der Fall ist
Was wiederum zu dem Problem führt, dass Overwatch League nicht wirklich
Also diese ganze Competitive-Szene ist halt recht dünn in Overwatch
Und Ranked ist definitiv kein Modus, wo man Nachwuchs findet
Ja, ein gut Ausnahme bestätigen die Regeln, damals kippt bei
Wie hießen sie damals? Reunited, Reunited, Reunited, Reunited hießen sie noch
Den haben sie auch gescoutet, glaube ich schon, in der Beta übers Ranked
Aber wenn du hier nicht gerade konstant Top 10 bist
Was schwierig ist, sagen wir mal so, als Support-Splash-Tank-Spieler
Dann wirst du da auch nicht gefunden
Mal gucken, ob die Widows spielen oben links, gerne Widows
Nope, bitte, nope, keine Widows
Chill ich mich da jetzt hin
Die gehen alle immer so hart rein
Was machen die da vorne eigentlich alle?
Was? Fakt ich dachte, der ist tot
Fakt
Nö, er war wieder da
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Der ist tot
Hätten wir jetzt mal eine mercy gehabt
Genji und schick du kannst doch viel mehr spielen als genji mittlerweile
Also hast du nicht auf übelst gut wieder gespielt josen ich bilde mir das ein du warst doch auf dem weg zum wieder meinen
Was machen die alle da vorne
Wann war hier nicht ein heal pack irgendwo war hier nicht irgendwo ein heal pack
Aber
Ich bin bereit!
Auf jetzt Leute, vor, vor, vor, komm
Komm
Hallo, damage machen, einer, please, come on, bro
So, ich geh jetzt auch vor, die gammeln alle so gerne so weiter vorne rum
vorne rum
Heim
Wo ist der Bastion am Start?
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck
Was war das denn? 5k ist das hochste, ja
28%, oh Gott, 28%
28%